round five of the sink yield cup here in  st. Louis the capital of chess is the US  with a restaurant tab the best players  on the planet came into the game going  all-out for victory  world champion Magnus Carlsen bounced  back from a terrible loss to be raining  branch as to a champion Wesley so  faulting Magnus diagonal and in a tie  for second place  Vishwanath on-on-on ripped apart from  Yano karana King in a game of Ages and  sent a clear message to the field as a  former champ is focused and ready to  take down his young rival the players  arrested that are said to charge into  battle once again rousing action coming  of that  [Music]